[ YouTube Learning ]
A lot of teachers have been asking me about
how they can start teaching their students online.
So I decided to make a series of videos about
how teachers could use various tools
within YouTube and Google Classroom
to start teaching their students online.
I’m Ganesh; I’m the founder of Don’t Memorise
and in this video, I am going to teach you
how you could quickly create a YouTube channel.
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
I started my YouTube channel 5 years ago because
I wanted to educate millions of learners,
and now I have a dream to educate more than
a billion learners in the coming years.
Each one of us has this passion or
burning desire inside of us,
to share something with the world
and your YouTube channel will help
you do exactly that.
So without further ado, let’s begin!
The only prerequisite to starting a YouTube channel
is to have a Gmail ID or a Google account.
If you don’t have one, you can create it
very easily by visiting accounts.google.com
and clicking on Create Account.
To create your YouTube channel,
head over to YouTube.com,
and you will see the Sign In button
on the top right corner.
Click on the Sign In button
and enter your Google Account credentials,
and then you will see a page like this.
DO NOT get overwhelmed
with all the buttons you see here.
You will understand everything with time.
On the top right corner of the page,
you will see a circle with a letter in it,
and by default, it shows the first letter of the name
linked to your Google Account.
When you click on it,
you will see the following options in a dropdown format.
Again let’s not be amazed by looking at these options.
Let me ask you a question here.
Where would you click now to
create your YouTube channel?
It’s self-explanatory right?
We click on ‘Create a Channel’
which will get us to this page!
Seeing this page should get you excited.
Your journey as a creator has begun!
Once you click on ‘Get Started’,
you’ll see this page!
Now, this is asking you if you want to
use your Google account name
or think of a custom name for your channel.
I’d suggest you go for the custom name option,
which will convey what your channel means or does.
The custom name I gave my channel
was ‘Don’t Memorise’
because I wanted our learners to understand concepts
and not just memorise.
Once you give your channel a name,
you will be asked to upload a profile picture.
You can do that immediately
or even later if you wish to!
And that brings us to the last and
one of the most important steps.
The channel description.
This is a very important field that you need to fill in
after giving it some thought.
This will not only help your viewers understand
what your channel is all about,
but will also help your channel with search rankings!
And then you can add your relevant links,
and click on ‘Save and Continue’.
There you go; your channel is ready now!
And hey, don’t worry,
all of these details can be changed later.
But hold on;
do you HAVE to upload videos
if you have a YouTube channel?
Or are there other advantages to it?
How else could we help students
with our YouTube channel?
Watch the next video to know more!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]